He will not
let it go. (man laughs)
You can tell he is Latin,
Latin people are tenacious
My name is Nick Barili
and I'm traveling the
country to sit down
with some of the
biggest Latinx artists
and help tell their stories.
The ugly question is,
why aren’t Latin
people succeeding?
When you come from
the neighborhoods that
that we come from,
you need somebody
outside of you
to tell you that you’re worthy.
I'm sure there's
somebody watching
who is probably in those shoes
when you were at that time,
figuring how am I gonna
make it out of this job,
to start my career?
I feel like if you've achieved
a certain amount of success,
you gotta give back.
You can’t pretend
it's not happening.
Why do you think not
as many people
are as vocal as you
are about this subject?
- Well, being vocal has its cost.
when I became very
politically conscious
I got a lot of hate.
"Go back to your country,"
"Go back to Mexico,"
which I'm not Mexican, but
I'll gladly go back to Mexico.
Cause it's a great country.
Hearing from one generation
to the next generation
I don't want you to go
through what I went through.
-No. I don't want any kid to go
-How do you maneuver
through the industry?
I got scars on my head from
hitting that glass ceiling.
(in Spanish)
To culture.
- Much love, much love.